for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so this video is just to kind of
organize everything that we said in the
previous videos one sort of chart or one
big picture really so types of back
types of decay we talked about alpha
decay beta decay positron emission
electron capture gamma decay start with
alpha decay the particle the alpha
particle is represented like this with
an a value of for zo2 the general form
when it comes to alpha decays you start
with a nucleus of with an AZN x you get
the a to decrease by for the Z to
decrease by 2 and the alpha particle is
emitted okay and as far as the change in
AZ and n are usually a changes it
decreases by for the Z decreases by 2
and B n decreases by 2 as well beta
decay beta particles represented like
that a of 0 Z of negative 1 beta minus
start with in a ZX we have met that beta
particle da stays the same and the Z
increases by 1 the particle combination
that allows us to happen is a neutron is
turned into a proton and that beta
particle or an electron right otherwise
runs electron so what happens is the a
stays the same right there's no change
in a Z increases by 1 and the N
decreases by 1 because a neutron is
turned into a proton and electron
positron emission looks similar to the
beta particle except the though the the
mass number is the same z is 1 and the
charge is positive so we start off again
with the azx mass number stays the same
the Z is decreased by one with the
emission of this particle and as far as
the particle combo or change it occurs
one proton is converted into one Neutron
and one positron so the a value we said
doesn't change Z decreases by 1 and the
n increases by one with the electron
capture we've got an electron which is
basically identical to a beta particle
and but the thing about electron capture
is the only one with the particle on the
left side of the general form of the
reaction of the reaction so we have a ZX
plus this electron to give a resulting
nucleus with the same mass number and
the Z decreasing by one the part of a
combination here is that one proton and
one electron come together to make one
Neutron so the a value doesn't change Z
number decreases by 1 and the n
increases by 1 so the effect of positron
emission electron capture on a Z and n
are identical with gamma decay we have 0
0 for the mass number and atomic number
respectively in the gamma symbol here
and gamma decay is basically just energy
all right we just get energy released
so we go from a high high energy excited
nucleus to a more stable one and this
usually accompanies one of the other
types of decay no particle combinations
or changes are happening here and
there's no change in the AZ or n ok so
hopefully that was a helpful summary
maybe this might be a good thing to
study once you've watched the other
videos which I encourage you to do if
you haven't already so hope that video
is helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying